[Musique]
c'est devant le mémorial d'edmond albius
au bocage à sainte suzanne qui a été
commémoré ce mardi 10 mai la journée
nationale des mémoires de l'esclavagé
l'occasion pour le département et les
acteurs publics et associatifs de rendre
hommage cette esclaves réunionnais et ce
à travers une nouvelle exposition
permanente près du jardin du patrimoine
et de la mémoire aujourd'hui c'est la
commémoration du 10 mai c'est la
commémoration la loi dit tito berra en
fait qu'ils considèrent l'esclavagé
comme crime contre l'humanité mais ce
qu'il faut retenir aussi aujourd'hui
c'est que au delà de cette loi c'est un
moment pour nous réunionnais de rendre
hommage à tous ces hommes à tous ces
femmes qui ont été réduits au stade
d'esclaves et nous avons un escarbilles
ans ici à sainte suzanne edmond fabius
qui ne pas
ses facultés ce qu'il a fait à savoir la
fécondation de la vanille mais il est
rendu célèbre dans le monde entier et
c'est à nous aujourd'hui
de ne pas oublier toutes ces personnes
parce que on les retrouve aussi à
travers l'économie à travers nos
quotidiens un rendez vous avec
l'histoire de la réunion célébrer en
musique et en présence des enfants de
l'école josé barreau de sainte-suzanne
ateliers ludiques coloriage
documentation le but enseigner
l'héritage culturel de l'île aux jeunes
générations
nous à la réunion en avait l'habitude de
fêter est en fait toujours le va
descente mais aujourd'hui qu il faut pas
oublier le 10 mai parce que c'est
important enfin l'esclavagé reconnu
crimes contre l'humanité et c'est
l'occasion jamais il vient de
s'approprier cette page de notre
histoire de parler du scoreur de ne pas
avoir honte de parler de l' esclavage et
surtout de tenir un discours en faveur
de la jeunesse au niveau de la
génération future ne peut pas parler
d'histoire si on n'associe pas la
jeunesse si on n'est ce pas là une
nouvelle génération donc il ya des
écoles de 7 8 ans qui sont venus
aujourd'hui participer à des ateliers
pédagogiques
il ya un jeu qui a été réalisé sur le
patrimoine de sainte suzanne il ya des
ateliers pédagogiques sur l' esclavage
sur la traite négrière
les enfants découvrent de façon ludique
ce qu'est l'esclavagé l'engagisme donc
c'est vraiment un grand moment d'échangé
de partage et bien sûr de fraternité des
ateliers qui ont permis aux marmailles
d'en apprendre un peu plus sur le
patrimoine historique de la réunion et
l'esclavagé tout en posant les bases de
leur futur citoyenneté
[Musique]